hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game uh from day one of the
knockout section of the
uh earthings masters uh a wonderful game
between levan aaron and hikaru nakamura
uh and uh well features the london
system so you know it's gonna be
a lot of fun uh without further ado
let's check it out i was gonna show it
yesterday i
uh couldn't get a uh i didn't have the
chance so i'm
showing it now before uh the start of
day two
so without further ado let's check it
out it's quite a quite a wild one uh 11
with the white pieces
opens with d4 sorry about that
uh with knight to f6 uh and now knight
to f3
uh by 11 we have d5 by nakamura and now
bishop to f4 so 11 goes for the london
system uh we have e6
and now comes e3 preparing to develop
the light square bishop
bishop to d6 and already uh we have a
lot of fun here bishop to g3
and the knights to e5 are the most
common uh moves
in this position but 11 goes to bishop
to b5 check and it doesn't really make
sense
why would you do this because the bishop
can be easily kicked away
uh but it's the to create very little
imbalances in the position and to throw
now hikaru off guard and maybe into some
unknown
uh unknown theory so here you could
defend you you could block with the
bishop
bishop to d7 but then if you do this
white can just go back and then you have
kind of a
weird bishop on d7 maybe uh so what also
you could do is maybe block with knight
to c6
but hikaru actually blocks with knight
beat to d7 and this is now a new move in
the position already from move five
uh so uh let's see what happens here we
have a c3
strengthening the center and now castles
by hikar we have knight beat to d2
and now queen to e7 just continuing
development
uh knight to e5 uh and now comes knight
to e4 so both players
put their knights on excellent central
squares and here
uh 11 trades knight captures pawn
captures and queen to c2 now threatening
to pick up that the doubled pawn
and hikaru defends it with f5 so this
kind of weakens the e6 pawn but it's a
it's a it's a very strong setup because
it's very hard to reach this e6 pawn for
white
and this is incredibly strong and since
all of these pawns are on light squares
here
uh it doesn't seem all that likely that
this light square bishop will do be
doing all that much in this game
so here 11 just trades it bishop
captures we have bishop captures
and now h4 and this is something you'll
see very often uh in the london system
white will put a knight on e5 start
pushing that h4 h5 h6 pawn up the board
and maybe not not even castle so here
bishop the b5
preparing that bishop to d3 move uh and
here
a4 11 even encourages hikaru to go for
it but first you have to remove the
defender of the d3 pawn so bishop
captures
uh on e5 with bishop captures and now
bishop to d3
attacking 11th queen queen to b3 now
putting pressure on b7
also the e6 pawn is now kind of exposed
and
b6 he car defends it like this also
prepares c5 to strike in the center
because the white is still in the center
of the board and the hikaru's king is uh
very nicely safe on the king side and
now comes
f4 and here you kind of don't want to
capture if you capture then captures
rook is coming to g1 there's going to be
a lot of pressure
on the g file even if g6h5 just breaks
through
so here after f4 we have h5 by hikaru
now really
keeping an eye on the g4 square this
pawn is not coming to g4 anytime
soon and now 11 says okay now i'm gonna
play king to f2
and now my king will be very safe here
and here levin's plan is actually
because uh he traded off both of the
knights and he has a bishop on this
beautiful e5 square the
the black slide square bishop is also
not bad but it's very hard for black to
get his pieces anywhere near white's
king whereas 11's plan is pretty much
uh clear he wants to play rook h3 rook
to g3
bring the rook up the board and then the
other rook will do the same
rook h3 uh rook h1 rook h3 and then
rook to g3 and then he will have double
rooks on the g
file and a whole lot of pressure here
and hikaru needs to figure out how to
deal with this plan
so he plays king to h7 uh he wants to
move the pawn to g6 so the bishop
doesn't attack it then maybe
defend the pawn from the behind with the
rook so
rook h3 uh 11 continues with his plan
and the g6 now we have rooked the g3
and now hikaru doesn't want to wait for
11 to just complete his plan so he
strikes in the center another very
principled idea
uh because uh whenever your opponent
strikes on the king's side you want to
reply by striking in the center and vice
versa
so here we have rook to g5 11 makes some
room for the other book this is like i
said the plan rook h1 rook
h3 the g3 not f3 and now
king the h6 uh by hikaru uh
we have b uh d captures in c5 b captures
on c5 and now
even c4 and now uh you can even uh get
the queen to this dark square diagonal
and you know a lot of
a lot of good things can happen here for
white so here rook to f7
helping out with the defense and now
queen to c3 as planned
we have queen to b7 by hikaru and
now comes a5 and here rook to c8
adding another defender to the to the c
pawn here
we have b3 and the queen to c6 now
so the e6 pawn is nicely defended and
hikaru has to wait and see
how 11 will try uh try to go for a
breakthrough here and lemon just
continues with his plan
rook to h1 it's a rather simple plan and
i mean
and it's so very natural because you
know everyone will always tell you
now the london system is bad but then
you when you see someone really strong
playing it
uh you're like wow this is totally you
know bulletproof because
you have a dark square bishop on e5
which is uh untouchable
because black has a light square bishop
and no knights and you your planet is
very simple just
bring the rooks up the board to the to
the g file
so here hikaru goes rook to b7
and 11 just continues with his plan of
rook to h3 but there was a very sneaky
move in the position
uh that levin could have taken advantage
of uh here so
even feel free to pause the video and
try to find the sneaky idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting it as
it's not
very easy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
either g4 or bishop to d6 or rather it's
both you have to play
both of those moves point is after g4 of
course you cannot
grab with this pawn because h5 is just
you know crushing
so black will have to capture with the f
pawn and now
bishop to d6 just crazy stuff
you give up the piece uh so so to
prepare queen coming to f6 and then you
want to put a lot of pressure here
and here black has to be very careful
how to defend you have to
try something like maybe you cannot
touch the bishop but it's very hard for
uh for black to even uh make a move here
uh because uh
rook captures and c5 is coming that c5
one is very vulnerable
but i'm just gonna show what actually
happens after this because this might
might as well be lost for black but it's
very funny if black actually captures
tim queen f6 threatens checkmate and it
doesn't matter if any of the rooks come
to help out for example rook g8
you just capture on h5 with check uh
only move is now king captures on h5 and
queen to g5 is checkmate
so there's a lot of poison in the
position so after this rook the b7 idea
11 could have gone for g4 or this but
it's a
it's a rapid game of course the players
cannot find all the moves so rook h3 he
just continues with his plan it's not
like hikaru can do anything about it
and rook the g8 by hikaru he now starts
defending the g6 pawn
rook h to g3 and now uh queen
king goes back to h7 uh we have queen to
c1 levana wants to play queen to d1
and put more pressure on the position
and the queen to e8 by hikaru now adding
another defender to the pawn here and
not now
queen to d1 and this is where the magic
really happens
uh as uh well there
there's danger in the position
definitely but hikaru here played rook
to d7
and now his position is lost so feel
free to pause the video and figure out
why the position is now lost again well
i give you a couple of seconds
and this is the last time in the video
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
you actually win black's queen and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's uh
actually rook captures on g6 and the
point is now
uh you have to capture with the queen
you cannot capture with the rook because
if you capture with the rook
you get queen to h5 check and now you
don't have rook to h6 because the queen
uh sorry
you don't have rook h6 because the queen
hangs so you have to play king the g8
and then it's just a very sneaky rook
captures on g6 check
king f7 queen h7 check you have to go up
the board and now of course
rook the g8 is checkmate so that's not
happening here so
while this is a very interesting after
this rook captures in g6 movie car had
to capture with the queen and then his
position is just lost
but there's a brilliant defense only one
move prior to this
instead of hikaru's rook the d7 move
hikaru could have gone queen to f7 and
now
the same idea doesn't apply but now you
know why because now the queen is
defended and now
if you were to try the same thing for
example rook captures here
now you can actually capture with the
rook rook captures queen captures
and now you can block with uh rook to h6
because the queen is defended and
black is just winning here so it's a
very very uh you know small difference
but uh you know
uh it it basically you know just uh
loses the game for black er with the way
he carl played it so rook to d7 bad
queen to f7 good so hikaru player rook
to d7 and now
uh levin's sacrifice is of course well
worth it so he captured on g6 now hikaru
has to capture with the queen
and now rook captures on g6 uh we have
king capture sun g6 and now king to g1
now 11 has a
queen and the bishop against two rooks
and the bishop and it seems like black
should have the
enough material to counter white but
those are bishops of opposite colors and
the light square bishop will not be able
to oppose
the dark square bishop and it's white
who's attacking here make no
make no mistake so here we have a6 by
black
and now king the h2 11 just improves the
position of his king
rook to b7 and now queen to a1 even
giving up the rook here now you can set
up some very deadly
traps like maybe bishop to h8 followed
by queen to f6
but hikaru goes for rook captures on b3
and now you can even make a quicker
queen lift queen to a4 now attacking the
rook
also preparing to bring the queen up the
board with rook to b1
it's very hard for black to organize an
attack if you could get your for example
rook here you can because the bishop is
there and somehow utilize the rooks then
maybe you could do something
but it's very hard queen to be seven by
eleven and now
bishop captures on c4 grabbing that pawn
but queen is seven and now
the queen is it can come to f6 the g5
and there is not much for hikaru to do
he played rook b
to b8 but he was also in this position
after playing rook beat the b8 on move
38 that hikaru nakamura resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
11 can just play queen f6 check for
example king h7
queen f7 check and now it's game over
king h6 and bishop to f6 this is the
star move
and there's no defense now whatever you
play bishop to g5 is coming
doesn't really matter rogue g6 bishop g5
check you have to give up
the rook and now f captures uh will be
checkmate as the king has nowhere to go
so after rook beat the b8 uh the game
ended and
a wonderful victory for levan arnon and
he's the only one who got a victory
yesterday uh other three games ended in
a draw so it's 11 who wins the first
match and now hikaru needs to win the
second one uh so we'll we'll see what
happens uh
uh in today's match uh so yeah
that's the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it a really a wild one and as
you can see
and not a very timid opening that london
system it seems like black was
black needed the like engine precise
plate to defend this position against uh
you know
11's on sloth but yeah uh again hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
bakas poor uh said
jefferson young cameron moat antoine
leboya and
joseph bessette for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing
uh the coverage of the second day of the
air things masters checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day